there's a report out tonight John that
that the Trump administration is
blocking Tony Falchi from testifying in
front of the House Appropriations
Committee anything on that yeah just got
a statement from the White House which
confirms that in fact that has happened
let me just read it to you really
quickly here this is from Judge deer
deputy press secretary says while the
Trump administration continues its
whole-of-government response - kovat 19
including safely opening up America
again an expediting vaccine development
it is counterproductive to have the very
individuals involved in those efforts
appearing at congressional hearings we
are committed to working with Congress
to offer testimony at the appropriate
time that's just breaking just in the
last few minutes so foul she is not
going anywhere near Capitol Hill at
least not for this foreseeable future
dr. Burks as well I imagine that they
probably keep Redfield away in addition
to that and probably Brett anybody who's
associated with the corona virus task
force all right John Roberts live in the
North Lawn John thank you